qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu faire ici
ce soir je suis conseiller en art ce qui
veut dire on a demandé à williston
braqueurs hors pair pourquoi ils
attaquaient des banques ça donne a
répondu parce que c'est là où est
l'argent
[Musique]
si ce taux n'était encore en vie il
n'attaquerai plus les banques ils
voleraient les riches c'est très
impressionnant
bingo je ne vais pas faire ça toute ma
vie je pense qu'il me reste de plus que
deux et j'avais vraiment adorable ton
père me devais beaucoup d'argent j'ai
l'impression que c'est peut-être en
train de réparer une des erreurs ou pas
c'est en servir on ne vit chez dans
l'autre sens
je vais vous aider mais de quoi vous
parlez je peux vraiment faire quelque
chose pour vous je m'appelle marguerite
je m'appelle karen élise et bien alors
amusez vous bien
[Musique]
vous êtes un couple si charmant
merci beaucoup pourquoi vous me suivez
lba ces trois dernières années à cause
de gars comme vous plus de 75 millions $
d'oeuvres d'art ont atterri sur marché
noir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça vous voulez
quoi qui est derrière tout ça écoute moi
c'est important
une toute dernière mission et on est
quittes tous les deux c'est quoi les
options mais option c'est mourir ou ne
pas mourir ok je crois qu'il ya quelque
chose que vous ne me dites pas vous
tomberez quand même ce sera peut-être
pas votre faute sera celle de petit ami
instable ou alors la frères bipolaire il
ya toujours quelque chose
pourrait aussi faire une minute de
silence
[Musique]
tu crois que tu vas avoir besoin combien
de temps mais enfin